The most people in Europe
are sympathetic to the plight of migrants and asylum seekers
and I welcome them.
But they expect it to be done in a fair and equitive manner
open to.
Now that was impossible because we are different systems across Europe.
So I welcome and this package
I think to bring coordination
in line with our obligations
on the international treaties and conventions
and will ensure that there's a cohesive and proper manner
in which asylum seekers are assist.
This notion that everybody can come to Europe,
legal and illegal, and stay here indefinitely,
that's upsets people and that's understandable.
They expected to be done and now we can do it in solidarity.
And I think once we do that and every member states places part,
we will head to have a proper structure
and also break the power of the people smugglers
who've got away with exploiting
the most unfortunate people in the world
for too long. Now I think we can get it done properly and fairly
and show that Europe is compassionate and walks in solidarity.
Come out gurutan! Thank you very much. So now